on to other news now in some breaking
news out of Lesotho where the Prime
Minister has resigned after months of
pressure over murder allegations Thomas
to Bonnie's coalition fell apart in
Parliament last Monday and he was asked
to step down by the end of this week to
make way for a new government - Bonnie
is suspected of conspiring to murder his
former wife his current wife has been
formally charged with murder they both
deny any involvement in her death let's
speak to our regional correspondent IRA
Mutasa who joins us live from Harare in
Zimbabwe this controversy Harrow has
been going on for some time now Prime
Minister table on a finally resigning so
what happens now
well he's formally handed in his
resignation to King glitzy the 3rd the
king could ask him to stay on as a
caretaker Prime Minister until a new
prime minister has been sworn in that
person will likely be Finance Minister
majora he's 58 years old what he used to
work for the IMF he is liked by
supporters of Tobiah and he's also liked
by people who don't like to money when
it comes to the army a political Adnan
say they were like Mitchell they haven't
really had to deal with him and they
feel that they will my daughter becomes
a couple of days now that this is not a
resignation he simply retiring because
he is too old but he's been under a lot
of pressure because he's alleged to have
been involved in the murder of his
former wife and the current wife has
been charged right for that he they both
deny the allegations so all eyes are now
waiting on what's going to happen next
with the courthouse right precisely what
is going to happen with that course case
involving the murder of his former wife
well two body had approached the
Constitutional Court and it asked the
court saying that a sitting Prime
Minister can not be charged now that
things will be different because he will
no longer be Prime Minister for a while
at least until the new one has been
sworn and so what is going to happen
next some analysts say the reason why
this took so long
TT took so long to resign is because he
was trying to buy time either to
organize a good exit package for him and
also to try and make sure that he gets
some kind of immunity that if he is
charged or that he won't be charged for
the his
alleged involvement in the murder of his
first wife so all eyes will now be on
the court and of course on the
inauguration it could be either today or
maybe even Wednesday or a couple of days
from now but or people people have
seated will know the way for it is after
the inauguration and what the
Constitutional Court will do nice with
regard to the court case thank you for
that Hara Mutasa live for us in Zimbabwe
still ahead